that's your dco and goal for Vancouver outstanding
goenda that was riddled by injuries a season ago
sit back and enjoy this one off the draw Jamie
alexc shot tipped High by Ellie tolin and out
in front tolin it was below the goal line
he got himself to the front of the net and
a good quick shot there by the big rig Jamie
alexc Oliver Bor strand from the wall popping
out the pepper pot Yanni Gore he'll wind it
blocked in front left at the D collected by
Brock besser and the Canucks will get it out
to Center Ice Phil Dees sey marked that time
by rer Evans tolven and flings it in the Kraken
will get a change soon the corner sorry Johnny
this line is continued where they left off
moving it back for Justin Schulz he'll send
it deeper for wber there you go change sides
here now you got no pressure Bovi dangles in
a one-time shz denied the Stick of Demco three
to the boards now and Dakota Joshua will sail it
out 53 seconds left in the Kraken power play
three minutes gone in Period one rer Evans
slingshot it back for Yamamoto Tyler Yamamoto
moves in over the line tolvan for Evans rer
Evans will look it over here he gets it back
from Shane Wright Evans now for tolven into
the line Yamamoto shut down quality save by
Deno and Vancouver will clear out even though
he does not take the shot it definitely open
things up yamamo with a nice little goal line
play Then mov that puck over to Tolen and he
went right down to the goal line and Yamamoto
spins around there JT makes a beautiful little
move and Demco real strong holds that goal line
and makes a good stop dozen seconds on the
power play Shane Wright bed down by Deno no
hesitation there by wri to shoot the puck G out
of the corner now a handoff it's Ellie tolvanen
walking the line is heavens and now right Shan
Wright will dust it off Take It Wide rer Evans
pot coulson's out of the box tolvanen thinks
about it shoots it off a stick off the glass
in play collected by Seattle's Evans now gourd
is handcuffed hurried up by Sheldon drives and
it comes out to Center good shot block there
from the veteran Matt Irwin played his college
hockey is UMass Amherst a steal by tanning Brandon
Tana the shot swallowed up JT I was here the whole
time know you guys come in whenever you please
JT Miller with a shot C down by guau I'm glad
we can change the Q JT to JT correct shulz
angles along Yamamoto hurried up burkovski
has room here he comes Andre burkovski goes
wide forced wide by Young breb now Evans from
alexc throws on the brakes Jamie Alexia down
low rer Evans HBL in shoots it blocker saved
Demco good control the rebound yamamoto's on it
here's Evans again he'll send it in good smart
play there didn't try to force it at all wber to
the slot good sticks by the Canucks Brock besser
will exit the Zone Anthony bili that was P suder
free agent signing by general manager just about
9 Minutes gone in Period one Christian wannan to
the wall Olson for the Kraken broken up malanson
out to Center stad long time NHL Greg Wan him
in fact he was born Christen was born in Quebec
City dad playing for the nordes now it's carried
in Devon Shaw signed as a free agent last season
with the Edmonton Oilers Shane Wright on the
spot big stop Deno the rebound they score Shob
malanson in the right place at the right time
and the Kraken her off and running sure makes
a great play but watch the play that Wright makes
he finds the puck and he shoots it he attacks the
net no hesitation watch the pass right there he
throws it out to malanson and he puts it into
the back of the net heck of a shift for this
line JT yeah I like that two-on one there sh's
able to find the puck through but the presence
of right to go with that backhand pass to the
middle there's going to be those little bit of
rust here but I've already seen some of that
chemistry with Alexander wenberg but their plays
through the neutral zone so I'm looking to see
more of that here in the second period okay we
kick on up the second period I know that but I
don't know what day it is now kale flurry will
get to it delmare over the line moves in still
thir is it okay I can't wait for Friday now Kier
in control no rimit awaiting as Brandon Tannon
through the slot off a stick flurry a shot locked
in front boiler moves it out for Vancouver rolls
in on Philip grow 8 minutes gone in the second
period tanet hurried up broken up Suter across
Garland scores Conor Garland with a well-placed
shot a Dandy for him 1152 left to go in the second
period tied at one well a couple of turnovers here
in the second period by the Kraken In Their Own
Zone and now eventually the kuu make them pay that
kept that Play Alive his can of turned it over and
and then Suter over to Garland and just places
this Puck perfectly over the left glove the left
shoulder stolen I needed somewhere to put my
book well our people will contact your people
and the investigation will continue and then
either let somebody come in and get it or as
once it's a frozen Puck it's 50/50 then you
could be able to pull it back shot good stop
again by Demco tolven And Delay shoots it he's
gone K toan in with the power play D Seattle by
one dto with a terrific stop right before this
but when he gets this Puck entry there's the
chance good save turn over and watch the
patience right there he doesn't shoot it
dries lost his stick and Ellie goes poting in
just gives himself a little bit more time b
giler is all over him boun to Center Ice
what will happen is the players will get
their shifts and be able to watch him to the
house kicked out by Demco now it goes to the
outside I don't know about after the ride
tonight out to Center tanip Belmar will cut
across here's shelz going wide out in front
Demco comes up big on Belmar assassin with
the tied up the stick on Belmar wasn't able
to extend those hands and good quality chance
there good strength by cart by tanov and and
ricochets right to Bor Strat toan in finds the
cat 406 left the Kraken by
two quick change for the Kraken catching
Vancouver off guard slightly gour across
one timer availability right there Tolan
keeps his stick presented right into the
back of the net Dem Call's not able to
get over fast enough but the Kraken have
done a good job throughout the neutral zone
now suor to the wall Anthony boiler taken
down by tolin and off Evans one a stop
by deor a couple of times and it stays
out the Edmonton Oilers are here on Monday Night
final home game of preseason 11 seconds left
Carlson with a shot denight by dord gourd will
move it out brought along by malanson with Demco
back in goal 1 second left pre-season win number
two that's Kraken hockey baby it's a 3-1 win